[Musik]
denn hier leute bevor das wieder losgeht
muss ich erst mal kurz sagen
entschuldigung für den ton an vielen
stellen oftmals also draußen war es sehr
windig in der halle war immer extrem
laute musik deswegen spitz teure uhren
und ich würde sagen es geht es los viel
spaß
gleicher wir können nicht endlos alter
ist das finde ich hier so läuten wir
sind jetzt da guckt euch mal das hotel
an picassos soweit wir sind jetzt hier
im europa-park ankommen wir sind hier in
einem wirklich schön hotel das so an den
englischen stil angelehnt ist oder
amerikanischen was auch immer ist
eigentlich ein bisschen blöd ich habe
hier so ein zimmer erwischt da kann man
eigentlich vom parkplatz raus so ein
bisschen rein gucken jetzt zwar nicht
viel aber ja man kann schon was sehen
also jetzt nicht mehr das zimmer sieht
eigentlich echt cool aus und zwar gibt
es hier eine wunderschöne lampe und da
einen wunderschönen fernseher wenn jedem
hotelzimmer auch aber man hat hier ein
großes bett und man hat einfach hier
auch noch zwei weitere betten also sowas
habe ich auch noch nie gesehen aber es
ist wahrscheinlich für die kids ich habe
aber keine kinder übrigens würde ich nur
sagen und man kann hier vom bett aus in
die dusche reingucken aber wenn die
person dann zu hässlich ist kann man
auch einfach so machen
naja dann ist hier noch die toilette und
das bad ist jetzt allerdings besonderes
deswegen wir gehen es gleich los ich bin
echt gespannt ich habe so was noch nie
miterlebt deswegen bin ich auch hier ich
weiß nämlich gar nicht ob sich das so
wirklich gelohnt hat jetzt 300 kilometer
bis hier hin zu fahren aber wir werden
sehen ich mag keinen block und wir sehen
uns gleich wieder schön dass wir unsere
einladung gefolgt sind immer ganz
ist das ihre aber kulisse ist lasst mich
den einzigen stück jetzt
und jetzt bleibt
leute also in dieser selbst die ganz
miss germany von den letzten jahren
wir setzen hier dass die für dieses jahr
herzlich
damit ist
dort haben
jetzt auch
es fragt
so läuft es da mit
die werden
[Musik]
sagt nein zu alkohol
das
wohnhaft ist auch das was dazwischen uhr
los
wir wissen dass ein markt
leider sei das zusammenschlagen
immerhin
aber können sie es
weil auch hier
rund 20 stellen und damit
ganz schön forsch ordnung
diese sollen
nummer
[Applaus]
letzteres übrigens bafa ein
und die habe ich jetzt
soweit ich habe mich jetzt gerade noch
umgezogen weil jetzt steht noch die
aftershow party an
ich freue mich sehr ich war echt schon
richtig lange auf keiner party mehr miss
germany 2018 wurde die nummer 18 ich
weiß nicht mehr wie sie heißt aber ich
habe von anfang an gesagt es wird die
nummer 18 und es wurde die nummer 18
alex hast du nicht von anfang an gesagt
dass die nummer 18 ich habe von anfang
an gesagt es wird die nummer 18 ah ok
gefühl ich würde noch mal kurz also
nächstes jahr muss ganz klar ich mit
jury wir sehen uns morgen wieder ich
wünsche euch einen schönen abend auch
wenn das gar keinen sinn macht gerade
aber wies guten morgen leute aus europa
park es ist halb zwölf wir müssen
eigentlich längst mal raus sein und ich
musste schon längst wieder zurück war
aber das haben wir nicht geschafft
deswegen machen wir jetzt selbst war auf
jeden fall richtig cool gäste noch vor
allem die party war richtig cool also
längst klar nach hause
bis gleich so leute dieses hotel
gefahren jetzt drücken ihr jetzt die
wochen gut von klugar gramm
soweit ich bin wieder zu hause das war
es ja irgendwie habe ich an meine total
vergessen noch weiter zu blocken also
ich bin schon seit gestern wieder hier
und wir haben heute montag ich weiß das
weil es kein extrem langer blog aber ich
hoffe natürlich das video hat euch
gefallen
und falls ja dann lasst auf jeden fall
noch nach oben da die mister germany
wurde die nummer 18
das ist irgendwie voll witzig den namen
kannte keiner ist zwar immer noch die
nummer 18 aber es war auf jeden fall
sehr cool also hat eine menge spaß
gemacht dankeschön für die einladung das
geht jetzt los nach nächstes jahr freue
ich mich schon auf die miss germany 2009
und ich wünsche dir noch einen einwänden
tag wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen
gibt's neues cooles video auf 3000